If you have ever taken a trip to Suntop Mountain
in the Mount Baker-Snoqualmie National Forest,
Washington State, then you may have come across
an old wooden structure - The Suntop Fire
Lookout.
Built in the early 1930s, the building was
used by the US Forest Service to keep watch
for any fires in the nearby woodland.
At one point, Suntop Fire Lookout would have
been manned 365 days a year, complete with
a bed for staff who were stationed there on
rotation.
The single story lookout house overlooks the
scenic valleys of the White River and Huckleberry
Creek, but you’re not here for an informative
tourist guide.
You probably don’t care about the frankly
fascinating history of the lookout and how
it was used as part of the Aircraft Warning
Service during World War 2, watching for enemy
planes.
No, you’re here because something much darker
lurks inside the Suntop Fire Lookout.
And even though it appears to be a simple,
one-story-tall wooden structure, it certainly
is not short on space.
SCP-3333 refers to an anomaly that the Foundation
discovered inside the Suntop Fire Lookout
house.
The building’s interior is a single, square
room, measuring fourteen feet by fourteen
feet, with large windows on all four sides.
When standing inside Suntop Fire Lookout,
looking up at the wooden ceiling, one will
immediately notice a trapdoor.
No big deal, right?
A lot of places have a ceiling entrance to
a small crawl space, there is probably nothing
behind the trapdoor, apart from a dusty, old
attic.
There’s a latch that maybe once had a padlock
there, but not anymore.
Opening the trapdoor will reveal a collapsible
ladder.
Should anyone be brave, or indeed foolish
enough, to begin to climb, then they’ll
soon find themselves right back where they
started, inside Suntop Fire Lookout.
Or so it will seem.
The thing about being in a place like the
Mount Baker-Snoqualmie National Forest that
surrounds Suntop Fire Lookout is that woodland
areas are teeming with life.
Not just plants and trees, but birds and other
animals of the forest.
You can never truly be alone in a setting
like that, there is always life everywhere
around you.
So, when you ascend the ladder, and climb
out right back into the Suntop Fire Lookout,
that is the first, most noticeable difference
you will find.
It may take a while at first, but the nagging
absence of something usually so abundant in
a forest will eventually become obvious.
It’s quiet, far too quiet.
No birdsong, or the sound of distant calls
from woodland critters.
Just silence, all around.
Anyone ascending the ladder will find themselves
in a copy of Suntop Fire Lookout’s interior,
one story higher than the ground level of
the small wooden building, with the stairs
leading up to the front door getting taller
each time to reach up to the higher and higher
building.
Now, you know the SCP Foundation and the types
of bizarre, inter dimensional anomalies they’re
used to dealing with.
Perhaps SCP-3333 is a mirror dimension, or
a plane of existence where sound doesn’t
travel.
It certainly seems to be identical to the
Suntop Fire Lookout, save for the lack of
any organic life outside.
Of course, it’s what you’ll find living
inside SCP-3333 that you may want to worry
about.
Climbing higher, up the next ladder and through
the next trapdoor, every time with the same
result.
You appear at another copy of Suntop Fire
Lookout, each one higher up than the last.
What first seemed to be an innocuous, unassuming
wooden building is now an endless ascension
up into the heavens, towards the unknown in
silence, without a shred of plant or animal
life outside.
As you climb, perhaps you start to think how
much higher these copies go.
This might even be the biblical Jacob’s
Ladder, connecting Heaven and Earth.
That would be nice, wouldn’t it?
If you were gradually climbing your way up
to paradise, it might make it worth the trip.
But SCP-3333 is nothing that pleasant.
You wouldn’t be the first to attempt this
long climb.
When the SCP Foundation first discovered SCP-3333,
a research detail set up an onsite base camp
to examine this spatial anomaly.
Their first exploration involved sending a
member of D-class personnel, designated D-4f68a,
up the ladder.
His D-number is a hexadecimal code that, when
translated to text, reads ‘Oh’, so we’ll
call him that for brevity’s sake.
During the first day’s exploration, Oh was
able to climb 184 iterations of SCP-3333,
communicating with head researcher Doctor
Williams below.
On the second day, Oh could see a pair of
figures standing motionless on a nearby ridge,
but the pair could not be seen by Doctor Williams
and the other researchers at the base camp.
Both figures disappeared shortly after Oh
spotted them with the camera he had been issued,
and he felt uneasy, almost certain that he
saw them point at him.
The next day, at the 345th copy of Suntop
Fire Lookout, Oh’s behavior started to noticeably
change.
Previously, he had been anxious about the
long climb, and hadn’t questioned directions
given to him by Doctor Williams.
Now, he seemed to speak more casually, resisting
instructions, asking Williams to climb back
down and even calling her ‘Doc’ instead
of ‘Doctor’.
Oh also reported seeing writing on the walls,
but there was no evidence of this on his camera.
It appeared that something had started to
affect him.
It was when Oh reached level 527 that things
seemed to change more dramatically.
Rather than SCP-3333 continuing upwards, the
copies of Suntop Fire Lookout no longer had
a trapdoor or ladder.
They seemed to be arranged side by side, in
a grid-like pattern.
Stepping out of the main doorway, Oh remarked
on the lack of sunlight, and a walkway that
connected directly to the front door of the
next iteration of SCP-3333.
Oh complained about the lack of natural light,
and again requested to be allowed back down.
Doctor Williams instructed Oh to use the flashlights
he was provided, but they wouldn’t activate
and their spare batteries had vanished.
Oh then noticed a sudden movement, and just
then his microphone and camera feed went dead,
almost as if someone had turned them off.
It appeared that SCP-3333 had something else
lurking up there.
Doctor Williams oversaw the second expedition
into SCP-3333.
This time members of Mobile Task Force Mod-0,
also known by the codename “Characteristic
Eigenspaces”, were sent up the ladder.
Their ascent through the various copies of
Suntop Fire Lookout were not as eventful as
Oh’s, with no signs of mysterious figures,
or anxious feelings that Oh seemed to feel
as he climbed.
When they reached level 527, where the copies
of the lookout stop progressing upwards and
spread out in a pattern instead, their lights
and equipment all seemed to be in working
order.
However, as the MTF team split up, one by
one they encountered some sort of anomaly,
or an effect of SCP-3333 that caused each
of them to vanish into the dark.
Either that, or something took them.
These MTF units reappeared confused, and Mod-5,
the team’s leader, Graham Purcell, issued
an order to retreat and the entire squad went
back down the ladders for several days until
they finally reached the base camp again.
The members of Mod-0 were adamant they did
not wish to climb SCP-3333 again, but Doctor
Williams was beginning to understand more
of the anomaly’s effects.
It appeared to cause abrupt changes to people’s
personalities, along with some sort of phenomenon
that caused things to appear and disappear
the higher one climbed.
Assuming these were the results of a memetic
effect, Doctor Williams dispatched a ‘counter
memetics specialist’ for the next expedition.
This specialist was a blind, deaf, and mute
woman known as Annette or the ‘Nullwalker’,
who communicated via a signaling system embedded
in her hand, but was otherwise immune to any
memetic influences.
Observed by Doctor Williams and Graham Purcell
at base camp, Annette made her way to the
top of SCP-3333, reporting that she was aware
of someone watching her from outside the copies
of Suntop Fire Lookout.
On her body camera, a flicker of motion occurred,
something looking through the windows that
ducked out of frame when the camera passed
in its direction.
At the apex of SCP-3333, Annette kept her
flashlight off, but reported that she could
detect blood, following it to what she assumed
was a body.
Sounds of movement surrounded her, and as
Annette switched on her flashlight, Williams
and Purcell saw that it wasn’t a body in
front of her.
Instead, it was a pile of rotting organs,
decomposing muscles and discarded bones.
And among the pile was a metal dog tag, that
read ‘MTF Mod-5: Graham Purcell’; the
same man who was sitting next to Doctor Williams
at base camp.
Well, the same man on the outside at least.
The explanation for everything going on inside
SCP-3333, all these strange occurrences and
disappearances, finally came in a video sent
from Doctor Williams’ cell phone.
In it, a panicked Williams, covered in blood,
was fleeing from something at the top of the
recursive stack of SCP-3333.
There was no memetic effect at the apex of
the Suntop Fire Lookout copies.
Nothing was causing the people that the Foundation
sent up to act unlike themselves.
They simply weren’t themselves anymore.
According to her frantic video, Doctor Williams
had discovered the truth about what else was
hiding within SCP-3333.
With just the right amount of vagueness and
intrigue, the research team had been drawn
in.
It was as if they’d been lured in by the
lights of an anglerfish, realizing their grim
fate only too late.
The D-class ‘Oh’, the MTF team, even Annette
had been replaced.
An unknown group of entities on the top level
of SCP-3333 had been carefully observing them,
waiting until they would not be seen to slip
in and switch places.
These entities had been creating imagined
anomalous effects, like Oh seeing figures
that weren’t really there, as a way of luring
more bodies further up the stack.
They wanted the Foundation to keep sending
expeditions into SCP-3333, to keep them coming
back.
The mass of organs, musculature, and bones
that Annette had stumbled across, revealing
the ruse, had once belonged to Graham Purcell,
before he was replaced.
You see, the entities residing in SCP-3333
weren’t just copying people.
They weren’t possessing them or mind-controlling
them, or even shape shifting to steal a person’s
likeness.
They were taking skin.
These creatures hollowed out Graham, Oh, Annette
and the MTF team, pulling out their innards
and crawling their way inside, filling these
fleshy puppets and leaving their internal
organs to rot.
These hollowed out people become vessels for
the entities of SCP-3333 to hide in.
The whole thing had been a trap, intentionally
exploiting human weaknesses, intrigue, unanswered
questions.
You know what they say about curiosity, and
these entities used it to bring more potential
vessels to the top of SCP-3333.
They pretended to be the people who they had
replaced, imitating them so the Foundation
would send more personnel to explore the tower,
increasing their supply of skins.
Graham’s dog tag had revealed the deception,
and Doctor Williams had escaped up SCP-3333.
The members of the research team that had
already been replaced were hot on her tail,
determined to catch and hollow her out too,
and by the end of her video, they had succeeded.
A month later though, a team delivering supplies
realized what had happened and the trapdoor
was sealed.
Suntop Fire Lookout was put under permanent
guard, but at least fifty personnel were killed
or replaced by one of the entities.
A new Mobile Task Force, Lamda-1 “Maxwell’s
Demons” was created to hunt down and neutralize
any of the entities that escaped SCP-3333,
but it’s still unknown how many left the
tower and are still out there somewhere, waiting
to use someone’s curiosity about the strange
and unknown against them.
Now check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of the
HMS Wintersheimer” and “SCP-3999 - I Am
At The Center of Everything That Happens To
Me” for more tales of anomalous terror from
SCP Explained!